[Music]
in three's a crowd News one two three
that's a crowd or a party submitted by
geo what did you do Oh what did I do
well I think you won't like this with
your hair and then he calmed it down a
man caught his girlfriend alone with
their threesome partner and took bloody
revenge what that's breaking the rules
right yeah because you're only if you
have a partner like that that you as a
couple chose as your threesome parties
your threesome partner you can only do
it together with them you can't go off
alone because then that's a twosome
that's cheating these are rules that I
never even knew about his rules about
that should do this 54 year old
boyfriend nice
he ended up finding his 30 year old
girlfriend with a 31 year old victim who
the male if I beat his ass yeah because
the boyfriend beat the victor guy oh it
was a sausage sandwich Danice was a
freak I wouldn't want a third partner to
be a guy oh that's right Brie I wouldn't
want another guy like where does the
additional dick go what goes here one
goes here she knows thank you I would
never do it with a girl like you've
never heard of a rotisserie before it's
actually called the Eiffel Tower okay
there it is is it really because the
guys can go like this they're holding
hands like this oh don't go bad for her
it really depends on what culture you're
from though seekers like Parisians
called the Eiffel Tower
Filipinos call it the nut Shawn you know
the rotisserie yeah not this report I've
actually never done that but because
I've always had a boyfriend and I feel
like I would only do that if it was like
with two dudes and a spring break that
I'll never see again like something like
that because you can't talk to someone
normal after that like that yeah you
know
I have eye contact anymore take your
ashamed I'm gonna deal with a boyfriend
I couldn't do it with like someone I
loved I'd go back and talk about it like
it's a science project like remember
when we did that thing yeah I gotta do
it this way but like I feel like your
boyfriend could ever get the image of
another guy's dick in your mouth
especially I felt our you're wrong
leaking fingers with another man's touch
there's like weird it still is you're so
touching the dude in there I don't want
another dick in a room yeah if I see
another dick in a room my dicks gonna
get a limp
that's why has to be like a party
situation of singles like we don't go
about five days I've never been single
that's my impression of yeah apparently
the three of them had met on Saturday
night and they agreed to have a
three-way but then the next day after
they agreed so I don't know if they
actually went through with the three-way
but let me agree to it and then the next
day when the 54 year old got home he saw
his girlfriend with the 30 oh they were
just getting started before it was a
warm-up it was like an appetizer yeah
they're like come on we were just
getting warmed up so he ripped off the
leg of a coffee table and started to do
oh my god yeah how did you know that if
that leg was gonna come on so fast and
you gotta go down reload have a [ __ ]
coffee tables leg it's those high ones
oh yeah cuz coffee tables are so low
you're never the frying-pan kick the top
off like boom then grab the leg yeah
that's pretty cool
it smells gangster I know I would have
never thought of that so you beat him so
badly that this dude has he was left
unconscious with severe head injuries
and apparently they're saying that he's
not expected to survive
that's not fair yeah so then when the
cops came the man the boyfriend
allegedly told the cops that the victim
was raping his girlfriend and that
that's why he attacked him but then the
girlfriend was like I enjoyed it was not
being sexually assaulted I was cheating
on him from the
that's crazy so maybe this girl like
just wanted to have sex with another
dude and then like talk to him like come
on let's do a threesome or something he
should have just been like oh you guys
get started without me and he gets his
clothes off and then he reaches around
the guy I'm a bad bad man I don't that's
how it see something worked right like
reaches around the guy I figured you've
reached around this way so the when
they're when they're doing missionary
you turn around and then you you have
the guy in the middle right it's a lot
of work what happened you [ __ ] with my
brain so hard try to put the puzzle
pieces together it's like bigger so
imagine if a couple comes up and then
you're like you're a guy and then you're
like hey want to do what was in his mind
just get the three spots threesome
started you like oh cool and then you're
like okay and then you're like wow
explain it is is more funny than I was
imagining right right so if I'm turned
on turned on
turned on right I'm turned on and I
let's say I'm staring at Jill then the
do becomes a fleshlight to me
he's a connection to you and I made the
dude my [ __ ] but I'm but I'm looking at
you but then you've got the dude's
coupon your day oh did I have them lick
it off yeah but he's my [ __ ] now he's
my flashlight then you know what girl
ass purses guy ass is completely
different - oh yeah there you go
yeah it's more hairy I think that's all
my eyes on you can you feel it though
what are you just going with yeah you
point out some scaly a skinny and like
butt hair like you should have taken
that back before you even said it dude
the white needs to go there for you to
take it back well sometimes you got to
go to jail right you gotta go to jail
you gotta explore options sometimes you
have to go to jail cause like if you go
to jail you gotta make you got 30 years
you gotta be a little bit more flexible
personal anecdote you can't be all
stubborn in jail right you make these
videos so fun yeah this guy's getting
persecuted for murder or what oh right
who knows the last thing that they leave
off here is that it's unclear how the
couple met or favi knew him previously
and that the man was still in the ICU as
of the last time they took that day yeah
okay this guy could literally not
protect himself so I wonder how how big
he was how small he was not only that's
what the the girl also got injured
during that whole well if you're
butt-ass naked and there's a [ __ ] ya
guy beating even though that good thing
that he was he was like [ __ ] her from
behind I hit from the back of the head
oh yeah in a state of rage she saw it
coming but you never saw it coming yeah
maybe she thought he was trying to join
in the gangbang and wrap around a buff
I'll come yeah there it goes you made it
come down but then what happened was
I never thought about that we've been
off the coffee table they like I always
try to think of my escape situation if
like a an intruder came in and tried to
attack me like what would I do what
would you do
my lawyers were into the bathroom and
lock it that's why I want a daughter I
want a weapon in the bathroom there have
time to put it together and stuff
speaking of self defense I was highly
disappointed in California because I saw
I I want a gut but I don't trust myself
with the gun because I'll kill people
kill myself yeah accidentally or on
purpose
no absolutely not it's definitely be
honest I'm very clumsy so I wanted to
get one of those self-defense you know
those salt guns right yeah you can't own
a California only California what the
[ __ ] is ridiculous good salt salt like
they issued salt pellets instead of wood
I heard assault no no assault gun like
it'll like [ __ ] you up but it won't kill
that person so at least me without guilt
Thurmond gets shot with a salt gun and
then they bury her alive it's supposed
to feel like a [ __ ] crazy-ass punch
to your [ __ ] chest it keeps me safe
so I won't die but it will [ __ ] somebody
else in case some [ __ ] happens but
California you can't have it why they
want the good guys dining California I
guess I don't know I want the [ __ ] raisi
I feel like if I didn't have my gun or
anything around I know exactly what to
do so if you're in ever in a dangerous
situation take your dick out and start
chasing the person that's trying to log
you oh yeah just start whipping out your
dick and you just start masturbating and
like run after them and then they'll be
like oh don't [ __ ] touch me and in
the run away what if they have a gun
they're part run away as soon as they'll
see a dick don't be confused like I
don't have a dick what do I do
Oh tell Steve about his dick well if I'm
alone then take out your titties yep
I'll be like what like it'll be like it
my dear right so let's not do that
just go BAM and then like they'll be
like oh [ __ ] and I just run like crazy
yeah I think keep all your weapons in
the bathroom run to the bathroom lock
that [ __ ] down that gives you enough
time to like build your fortress to come
but if they have a gun they could just
start shooting the door of the bathroom
no but that's why I would have a
unassembled gun in the bathroom which I
don't have yet when you run into the
bathroom like let's say you should you
close the door on me how would you start
shooting through the door that proof
bathroom door okay but you would hear
the person come in the front door and
that would give you some time to get in
the bathroom so you're looking for you
first
that's true it's in the perfect
situation your [ __ ] work yeah my only
plan right now yep it changed it now
because you've just published so now
there's a couch leg I mean a coffee
table leg in the picture I feel like we
could learn a lot about like protection
from animals and in like you know like
skunks they'll fart
you know or like like dogs don't bite or
like the ink yeah with the squid with
ink
yeah that's your [ __ ] mm-hmm you got to
think of all the other like how can you
use your body Kevin McCallister has
marbles yeah so if you don't have a
weapon and you don't want to fight I
think we should learn how to poop on
command because I think the most
dangerous things is a biological weapon
I feel like I would [ __ ] if someone was
coming at me with a gun yeah and then
just grab it and [ __ ] throw it in
their face like don't run this way
though cuz in the shell running
[Music]